لن نضل تحت الوصايه الامريكيه ما فهمتم
على اوروبا ان تصحوا من سباتها هكذا
اعلنها مكون من وسط الاراضي الصينيه
تقف مصدومه تلبي طلب طباخ وترسل باخطر
اسلحتها و400 الف جندي اوكراني يتحضرون
للرد بما بوتين يحرك سفنه العسكريه في
البحر والهدف مدينه اوكرانيه جديده تطلب
النجده يعطي وعودا بتوزيع الاراضي
الاوكرانيه على الجيران الوثائق المسربه
تفوح منها روائح الخيانه واداره بايدن في
ورطه واوكرانيا تغير خططها بينما الغرب
يمد كييف بطائرات معطله فهي العجب برا
وبحرا وجوا الصين تطوق تايوان وال المتحده
ترد عسكريا
1400 صهيوني يقتحمون المسجد الاقصى بينما
الوضع في تل ابيب يقترب من الاشتعال اكثر
بدايه الحرب على ايران وسوريا معركه تحديد
المصري الحرب طالته وبدا الروس يشعرون
بالملل لتدخل موسكو بخطواته ثقيله ومرعبه
للساحه الاوكرانيه وتضرب باعتى الاسلحه
هنا قائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه
والاكسون
لجات الى استخدام استراتيجيه الارض
المحروقه بكثافه في مدينه بينما صرح
المتحدث باسم الجيش الاوكراني ان القوات
الروسيه تحقق نجاحات تكتيكيه في المدينه
مضيفا ان الوضع فيه بخموت بات صعبا جدا
ليكشف هنا زعيم مجموعه
ان اوكرانيا تستعد بنحو الف مقاتل للهجوم
المضاد والذي يبدو وشيكا حسب تعبيره لترد
موسكو باجراء مخيفه حيث حذرت القياده
العسكريه الجنوبيه في الجيش الاوكراني من
ان القوات الروسيه دفعت بسفن اضافيه الى
البحر الاسود محمله بصواريخ من نوعك
واضافت ان احتمال وقوع هجوم صاروخي واسع
النطاق على مقاطعه اوديسا والمقاطعات
الجنوبيه الاخرى يزداد خطوره وكان روسيا
تقول للاوكران تحرك بتحرك والبادئ اظلم
وخلال ذلك اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
قواتها قضت على حوالي 500
جنديا اوكرانيا كما دمرت عده مستودعات
اسلحه للعدو على مختلف محاور القتال خلال
اربع وعشرين ساعه ومن ساحه الحروب
العسكريه الى الحروب اللوجستيه وبعد تسريب
وثائق هنا مصدر مقرب من زلنسكي يعلن
انكيفي اضطرت لتغيير خطتها العسكريه بحسب
سي ان ان تلك الوثائق كانت اخطر مما هو
متوقع فبرغم ان واشنطن قد اخترقت العمق
الروسي وتجسست على الخطط والتحركات فانها
كانت لا تحذرك بموعد ومكان الضربات سوى في
بعض الاحيان هل تخاف امريكا رده الفعل
الروسي ام انها لا تريد للحرب الاوكرانيه
ان تنتهي ليس ذلك فحسبه بل ان هذه الوثائق
كشفت عن وجود قوات للبيت في اوكرانيا تتبع
فرنسا وامريكا وبريطانيا وهي نشطه هناك
وفق صحيفه الامريكيه لم تنتهي التسريبات
هنا فالكرملين وعلى لسان متحدث
يقول ان التسريبات والمعطيات تفيد ان
الولايات المتحده تراقب منذ فتره طويله
رؤساء الدول خاصه في العواصم الاوروبيه
لذلك لا يمكن استبعاد ان تكون واشنطن قد
تجسست على فهل تتجسس واشنطن حتى على
حلفائها يا ليست بجديده فامريكا لا تامن
احدا
وقال ان هذه التسريبات مثيره للاهتمام
ويتم دراستها وتحليلها بدقه كبيره كما يتم
تداولها ومناقشتها على نطاق واسع لكنه نفى
اي تورط لروسيا في هذه التسريبات قائلا
اصبح الميل الينا ويجعل من روسيا شماعه
ليعلقوا علي كل شيء وفي كل زمان ومكان مرض
شائع لا يوجد شيء للتعليق عليه هنا ومن
المعارك اللوجستيه نعود الى ارض الحروب
العسكريه وفي مفاجاه غير متوقعه وزير
الدفاع سلوفاكي يقول ان الطائرات التي
زودوا بها قادره على لكنها عاجزه عن تنفيذ
مهام قتاليه ومجله ديل تيليجرام تقول ان
خبراء روس خدعوا السلوفاك وتمكنوا من
تعطيلها وكما يقولها الجزائريون اللي يزرع
الريح يحصد غباره وبما ان الحرب تميل
للجانب الروسي فها هو يعلنها علي وعلى
اعداء حيث وعد الرئيس الاوكراني نظيره
البولنديه
بمنح بولندا اراضيه غرب اوكرانيا مقابل مد
بورسو يد العون للكييف في الهجوم المضاد
المرتقب خلال زيارته الاخيره لورسو بحسب
صحيفه انفيدي لننتقل الى بيلاروسيا حيث
اكد رئيسها الكسندر لوكيشنكو ان بلاده
بحاجه الى ضمانات من روسيا كجزء من
اراضيها لحمايه بيلاروسيا في حاله اي
عدوان خارجي مضيفا انه قد يتعين على بلاده
وروسيا اعتماد معاهده جديده تضمن امن بي
لاروسيا بشكل كامل وكما يقولها العرب
الحامي الله ولا يدخل البحر الا من يجيد
السباحه الصين تطبق على تايوان
التوترات على اشدها الاصابع على الزناد
ورائحه الحرب تنتشر في الارجاء وهنا تصعد
خطير ينذر بحدوث مواجهات في اي وقت بعد
زياره رئيسه تايوان للولايات المتحده هي
الصين تجري تدريبات واسعه في قناه باشا
التي تفصل تايوان عن الفلبين حيث اكدت
بكين ان طائرات تابعه لها تحمل ذخيره حيه
اجرت محاكاه لتنفيذ ضربات قربه تايوان
مشيره الى مشاركه حامله الطائرات شان دونج
في المناورات العسكريه التي تجريها حول
تايوان هذه التدريبات تحاكي ضرب اهداف
رئيسيه في تايوان وتشمل تطبيقا كاملا
للجزيره وشل حركه يامن حيث السيطره على
البحر والبر والمجاري الجوي والاتصالات
بحسب رويترز لترد تايوان بالاعلان ان
قواتها الجويه في كامل استعدادها للرد على
عنوان صيني هناك اجرى الجيش التايواني
تدريبات بالدبابات والعربات المدرعه
وعرباتهم في مقاطعه تينشو شمال الجزيره
لكن الرد الحقيقي جاء هذه المره من
الولايات المتحده حيث اكدت وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان واشنطن لديها الامكانات
والقدرات للحفاظ على امل المنطقه لتعلن
البحريه الامريكيه ان المدمر ماليوس التي
تحمل صواريخ موجهه ابحرت في مياه بحر
الصين الجنوبي هناك اعتبرت بكين ان
المدمره الامريكيه توغلت بشكل غير قانوني
فكيف ستنتهي تلك التهديدات ومن المناورات
والتوغلات الى قلب الطاولات وبعد زيارته
الى الصين الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل
اوروبا ان تقلص ارتباطها بالولايات
المتحده وان تتجنب الدخول في مواجهه
محتمله مع بكين في قضيه تايوان فهل اقتربت
اوروبا بذلك من تجاهل الامريكان والانضمام
الى حلف التنين الصيني
الاحداث والتطورات
قال الدائره الاوقاف الاسلاميين اكثر من
20400 مستوطن اقتحموا المسجد الاقصى على
دفعات للحمايه امنيه مشدده من شرطه
الاحتلال ومن جهه اخرى قال رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي
ان الجيش الضرب اهدافا ايرانيه في سوريا
وان دمشق تعرف انها فقط مجرد بدايه مؤكدا
ان تل ابيب جاهزه لتنفيذ عمليات كبرى في
كافه الجبهات ان اقتضى الامر افتتح الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان خط مترو بشاك شهير
كايا شهير الجديد في اسطنبول وهو اردوغان
يظهر وهو يقود القطار في اول رحله له
بينما اعلن الرئيس التركي ايضا عن تشغيل
اول حامله الطائرات تركيه تي سي جي اناضول
الاثنين المقبل وتسليمها الى القوات
المسلحه في البلاد روسيا تحرك اسطولها حول
اوكرانيا بينما تقترب مدمرات الامريكان من
الصين واو روبا تقول وداعا للوصايه
الامريكيه فهل حان وقت الحرب الطاحنه
[موسيقى]